if I tell you that someone talked sense
on fox news you would immediately know
that it was either shepard smith or less
likely but possibly chris wallace
someone talked sense on fox news
yesterday insta fact-checking Donald
Trump's bogus claims about Amazon and
Jeff Bezos straight-up telling his
audience none of what you heard was true
and it was indeed Shep Smith let's check
it out we're gonna start with Donald
Trump's claims about Amazon and their
deal with the post office that Trump
completely misunderstood he also took
aim today again today at Amazon the post
office is losing billions of dollars and
the taxpayers are paying for that money
because it delivers packages for Amazon
at a very below cost and that's not fair
to the United States it's not fair to
our taxpayers and Amazon has the money
to pay the fair rate at the post which
would be much more than their thing
right now we're giving a subsidy to
Amazon and we're talking about billions
of dollars a year but the real cost and
a report just came out they said $1 47 I
believe or about that for every time
they deliver a package the United States
government meaning the post office loses
$1 47 so Amazon is gonna have to pay
much more money to the post office yeah
okay so that stuff is not true it's just
not but usually you don't hear that
fact-checked on Fox News but look at
Shep Smith go the Postal Service's own
numbers show it makes money by
delivering packages for Amazon and other
companies as for taxpayers the post
offices own website points out and I
quote the Postal Service receives no tax
dollars for operating expenses none and
that reference to a dollar 47 that the
president came up with they're a
Citigroup study last year showed on
average the Postal Service was charging
a dollar 46 below market rates or
package delivery but our researchers
point out if that discount exists it's
not just for Amazon it's a bulk rate
discount back to John Roberts there is a
great deal of confusion or something
here regarding Amazon in the post office
because none of that none of that was in
it was true that's right it's just not
true and it's too complicated to explain
to Trump and the entire Amazon package
delivery world is super interesting
aside from whether we like or dislike
Amazon is a company aside from whether
Trump gets it
there's a lot of really interesting
stuff Amazon does they have huge market
power they strike deals with UPS and
FedEx and the post office they purchase
a fleet of planes to do some of their
own shipping it's all really interesting
but as far as what Trump is saying the
bottom line is that USPS offers $1 47
bulk rate discount from market rates
it's not necessarily a loss it's just a
discount it's not just for Amazon and
the reason for all of this stuff is
partially that Trump just doesn't like
Jeff Bezos because Bezos owns the
Washington Post and The Washington Post
has been doing really good critical
investigative journalism related to
Trump's administration and then behind
all of this is probably the idea as
we'll touch on with Corey Dugan next
week when he's back on the show that
Trump would love to privatize USPS to
some degree the way he wanted to
privatize the VA and just likes the idea
of privatization but I don't want to get
hugely off track I've explained this
before the biggest reason that
conservatives say we should privatize
the post office is because on paper
they're not doing well financially which
is because they are required to pre-fund
something like the next 50 or 75 years
of retirement benefits for employees
which is absurd I'm forgetting the exact
details offhand but in any case it's
it's it's Trump likes to call it this
was a Nancy Pelosi beauty or an Obama
beauty it's a right-wing beauty to
constantly go back and talk about
privatizing the post office and that
that's just something that I don't see
happening anytime soon
people wondering how does Shep Smith get
away with this stuff
a couple possibilities-- he might have
an ironclad contract I don't know about
that the other possibility is that it's
sort of calculated by Fox they say
listen we're gonna let Shep say whatever
he wants the rest of the network is
complete right-wing lunacy and then
anytime we get called out we can always
say listen we've got a range of opinions
on the show we've got all this stuff and
then we've got
Shep Smith and they can sort of use Shep
to try to deny their bias ultimately
it's very very fun to watch the trumpets
go into cognitive dissonance shock how
how can Shep be doing this how can any
of this stuff be true they're disrupting
my echo chamber yeah and you know Trump
takes everything he hears on Fox News is
gospel true so maybe this will cause him
to reevaluate his position on this maybe
he'll figure out that he was wrong about
Amazon in the post office my sense is
he's just not watching Shep Smith I
don't know I've never even heard Trump
mentioned awareness of Shep Smith at any
time so I think it's mostly Fox &
Friends and Hannity that Trump is uh
sort of paying attention too let's take
a quick break Amanda Marcotte joins me
next today's program is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses which I
now have two pairs of Warby Parker
offers a free five day in-home trial of
their glasses you try five pairs you see
which you like I wear contact lenses on
the show but I often wear glasses at
night and on weekends and both of my
pairs of Warby Parker glasses are great
I did the free at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I like the most sent them
back typed in my prescription online and
soon I got my finished glasses with my
prescription in the mail and I love this
because when I'm at a glasses store
trying on glasses I can't really figure
out if I like them because I feel the
pressure of the salespersons gaze on me
I want to show the glasses to other
people I need time to figure out which
glasses I want to commit to and the
eyeglass industry is also controlled by
a tiny number of companies which keeps
prices very high I even know people who
have spent over three hundred dollars
for a pair of glasses but with Warby
Parker there start at just $95 that's
what mine costs to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
war V Parker trial comm /t DPS